jamais depuis l'avènement la 5ème public
la france n'a connu une telle
humiliation oui monsieur previstage de
la france est humiliée bien sûr nous
condamnons comme vous monsieur prix mini
stre les agissements de nos alliés
américains britanniques et australiens
mais force est de constater que cette
affaire dit des sous marins australiens
en dit long sur votre gouvernance est
votre bilan le contrat du siècle évaporé
la place de la france radio nadeau
pacifique écarté et la place de la
france sur les chaînes nationales et
rabaissé et je crois que vous devez la
transparence et la vérité aux français
vous la devez également à la
représentation nationale donc je pense
qu'il est important de répondre à des
questions simples d'abord comment
comprendre que ni l'elysée ni matignon
ni le quai ils nos ambassades nos
services n'ont vu sur entendu ce qui se
tramait avec la rupture d'un contrat est
une nouvelle alliance au cuss
quel ministre croire monsieur prévenir
quand nous avons deux versions
différentes entre les ministres français
et les ministres australiens
comment comprendre l'avenir dorénavant
après les propos de complices sur l'otan
et la place de la france dans l'otan et
quelle place pour la défense au niveau
européen et enfin monsieur le premier
ministre
quel avenir de pour nos intérêts et nos
français la liste a rappelé plus de 10
millions je pense à ma nouvelle
calédonie dans un espace où la chine sam
de plus en plus je vous remercie on vous
répond de la parole est à blâmer
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs sueur sénateur
permettez-moi d'être étonné pour ne pas
dire choquée d'entendre dans cet
hémicycle un responsable et un
représentant de la nation donner le
sentiment qu'au fond ce qui arrive à la
france est plutôt un motif d'
instrumentalisation du débat politique
interne plutôt que plutôt que deux
plutôt que monsieur le sénateur de
considérer que c'est la france sa place
dans le monde et ses relations avec ses
partenaires ses alliés au premier rang
desquels les états unis qui est en débat
c'est une question sérieuse qui me
paraît devoir nécessité la mobilisation
de chacun
les français auront l'occasion de
s'exprimer sur les débats de politique
intérieure dans quelques mois alors si
vous le voulez bien revendre 11 ans à la
sphère qui nous intéresse cette affaire
vous le savez c'est c'est une rupture de
confiance parce que rompre un contrat ce
n'est pas voir une la confiance c'est
rodez vous connaissez le sens des mots
la rupture c'est brutal et ça ne
s'anticipe pas et c'est ce qui s'est
passé monsieur le sénateur car lorsque
jean yves le drian et moi même nous
avons tenu avec nos homologues
australiens le 30 août une réunion qu'on
appelle le 2 + 2 qui sont des réunions
que l'on tient avec des partenaires
stratégiques comme l'australie et que
lors de cette réunion il a été confirmé
l'importance majeure de ce contrat de
sous marins vous pouvez convenir
monsieur le sénateur qu'il s'agit d'une
forme de duplicité et lorsque le premier
ministre australien écrite au président
de la république le 15 septembre au
moment où l'annoncé faite et qu'il dit
que le programme de sous-marins classe
attaque et le meilleur sous marins de
classe océanique dans le monde vous
comprendrez bien monsieur le sénateur
qu' on ne peut pas à réécrire l'histoire
a posteriori ou alors évidemment on
s'érige en juge ou en procureur ce ce
que non je comprends d'ailleurs que
c'est l'intention du sénat et vous aurez
puisque
[Musique]
suivez les provocations non pas une
utilité absolue pour éclairer le débat
et comme vous le savez mesdames et
messieurs le sénateur c'est toujours
avec plaisir que je ne plie aux
commissions aux questions du sénat donc
je le ferai
je ne ferai comme je les ai toujours
fait
je le ferai comme je les ai toujours
fait mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
mais je pense que dans cette affaire
nationale ne ferait pas de mal monsieur
rachid et m
[Musique]
madame la ministre
malheureusement encore une fois votre
réponse est à côté comment dire
aujourd'hui que quand le parlement et le
sénat fait simplement son travail qui
est le contrôle nous serions dans une
logique de procureur nous pourrons
sablon des questions légitimes dès le 2
juin dernier un article dans un grand
journal australien évoqué la difficulté
sur ce contrat là vous n'avez rien dire
et fait ce que je note c'est que la
gesticulation diplomatique qui est fait
par votre gouvernement n'est pas à la
hauteur d'un pays comme la france et
c'est pour cela que nous demandons
encore aujourd'hui plus que jamais une
commission d enquête sénatoriale pour
que la vérité soit faite et que
d'enseignement soient tirées je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]